[Music]
i went through all of her apps
everything like three different
snapchats tick tocks uh multiple
apps with
explicit
screen names any other screen that she
has access to at all period is a choice
for an adult to ruin her life
[Music]
you better believe it it's the dr john
deloni's show i'm so glad that you're
with us
whether you're exhausted you are cooked
you're completely burnt out you were
laughing this morning you're tired you
were staring at a
sink full of dishes you are staring at a
lawn that needs to be mowed and it's not
happening or you're driving into work
today or you're coming home from work
today and you're like what am i doing
with my life i'm so glad that you're
with us
so glad that you're with us we talk
about mental health relationships
anything you can think of what's going
on at schools all of it um so give me a
call if you want to be on this show uh
give us a shout
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-3291
or you can send us an email go to
johndaloney.com ask i guess it's not an
email you go there and fill out the form
on the interwebs and it goes to kelly so
um man i'd love to talk to you give us a
shout let's go to gail in jacksonville
florida hey gayle what's up
hello how are you i'm remarkable how are
you
i'm getting by i feel like i checked
almost all of the boxes you mentioned to
begin with except for going and coming
home from work today well welcome to the
gang i'm glad you're with us
so what's up how can i help
okay um so i need a little advice or
help on uh
how we reestablish trust
re-establish
some
boundaries and rebuild some trust with
our teenager okay
so what happened
a lot
um so she got suspended from school
uh first time ever this has never
happened um she's typically a good kid a
b honorable uh
you know goes to school does her thing
comes home she does all her chores she's
a great kid
but she apparently shared
uh texted
a picture of one of her friends that i
guess she was having a falling out with
um
it was a nude picture or partially nude
and she shared it with another friend
okay
um and then found out that that friend
was going to send it to somebody else
and that the girl that was in the
picture
uh was about to go to the authorities so
she turned herself in we didn't know all
of that to begin with but she just said
she did the right thing she turned
herself in she didn't want it to get out
of hand but
really it came down to it was about to
come out anyways okay
so
that's what happened to begin with she
uh she got suspended luckily the parents
didn't press charges it didn't go crazy
out of hand
but she did get suspended for a few days
we had some major
talks
totally took away her phone um
the school had went through her phone
her dad went through her phone
um but then when i went through her
phone i discovered that the reason they
didn't find these things is because she
had deleted the app
um so i we had her write down all of her
passwords to everything
i went through all of her apps
everything um
found a lot of uh
snapchats tick tocks like three
different snapchats tick tocks uh
multiple
apps with uh explicit
screen names and some
pretty trashy photos and she had
well over a thousand followers
and this is a very introverted kid very
introverted
um
you know so we
explained to her the dangers of all of
this you know thought that we we do a
good job talking and communicating and
things but uh
um
then we discovered uh after that that we
thought we took all the appliances but
turns out she still had her air paws and
another iphone
took those from her
then i discovered she goes to her mom's
every weekend
um and i found out that she had another
iphone over there and an ipad over there
um so i set the screen time turned all
that stuff off told her to bring the
other iphone back she brought it back
went through everything
and then
uh found out that there was some
pictures and videos in there of her
smoking weed
with this friend that her mom felt like
she was a bad influence and and she kind
of was yeah um the friend was smoking
weed and we knew that her her parents
did but uh or her dad anyways yeah um
but she never goes
does these things with us it's only
it's only when she's at her mom's
honestly all these pictures all these
videos all this stuff now i'm sure that
when she's at our house she yeah
i would say that you that you know of
right
right right well all the all the
pictures i mean i can tell in the
background and where she's at and
everything yeah so let's fast forward to
today
um
before we get to today is
her mom on board with this
no no not at all she grounded her for
one week after the original
uh nude situation came out but when when
mom saw found out about all her accounts
and all of the pictures she's posting of
herself and all that there was nothing
no it's all good no she she kept her
home for the weekend
um
basically to babysit her other child so
she can go out and do her thing okay um
so and then told her the next week she
could go to hang out with her friends
now whenever he
confronted you know told showed her mom
the pictures of the girl that she
thought was a bad influence he's like
listen yeah this is why
you're right she is a bad influence you
know
we've known this for a while but yet you
still keep letting her go over there you
still keep letting her do things with
this kid and look these are the videos
to show you of what she's doing with
this kid
and she got very defensive about it she
thought he was attacking her parenting
and he is
yeah and i'm attacking everyone's
parenting all right so here's here's let
me give you some context and then
uh
i don't think the legal part of this is
over
i think there was probably a lot of
pressure to not make this a big deal and
if you don't say anything this can kind
of go away
this is the kind of thing that will
resurface
and
while your daughter is really lucky they
didn't press charges i kind of wish they
had of
right because that's the only way
this is such a big deal
it's such a big deal
um
for a thousand different reasons here's
so imagine this imagine y'all had a
neighborhood
and in your neighborhood there was the
occasional burglary there was the
occasional you know somebody got in in a
fight
and so
let's say you had a loaded gun in your
house just in case
just in case
i have that okay just in case
right
and then you thought you know what's a
good idea let's give it to our 15 year
old she should carry it
um
we'll just tell her about it
we'll just tell her hey make good
choices
um but uh just in case
would anybody do that
no no no and i i've heard you explain
this in in another one of your shows uh
giving a kid a chainsaw
i explained that yeah to him as well
because i've been saying for a long time
you need to monitor this you need to
look at this this isn't this isn't about
monitor
this is scorched earth
any any other screen that is given to
this child
this child any other screen that she has
access to at all period
is a choice for an adult to ruin her
life
because she's a kid
the fact that she's an introvert i could
care less you know what she has
a thousand people
saying we see you and we think you're
beautiful
a thousand people
telling her that she's got validation
through their thumbs up or their heart
emojis or through their private dms or
whatever
and i don't care what kind of parent no
parent can compete with that
especially apparent
dealing with divorced home and who loves
me and who's giving me what i want and i
want
this parent makes me eat vegetables but
this one makes me eat pizza so i love
them more all she's a kid
and so
if i'm you i
it's not about challenging stepmom i
mean real mom's parenting
it's not about that
it's about saving this little girl
and i would go as far as to take those
pictures to the authorities and say this
is happening at this other person's
house
like i mean you hear what i'm saying
this is not about preserving like i
don't want to get her in trouble i don't
embarrass her we are so far past that
i'd call the cops i'd call the i would
get my attorney and say hey we need to
resurface this because mom is putting my
daughter in an unsafe situation is that
going to do anything no it's going to be
drama and a bunch of nonsense but that's
the level i'm at because here's what
we're doing now now i want to paint a
picture that 10 years later
if my daughter's not in jail if my
daughter's not involved in stuff that
she can't walk back
i want to have a trail of honey i fought
for you
i went to court for you i called the
police for you i did everything from you
and this little 15 year old
is that all she's 15 16 how old is she
15 she'll be 16 soon yeah gosh
this little 15 year old
is gonna feel like you are ruining
everything
and this little community of hers is
thousand people who likes to look at her
erotic pictures and all
like this is her lifeline right now and
so when you cut that off it's gonna feel
like the end of time for her both both
this isn't like oh this whiny kids no
this is like gonna be an emotional
physical thing
her brain will scream reconnect
reconnect reconnect that group of people
tells you that you have value
and yes if my ex says i can't believe
you're challenging my parenting yes
yes and so are the courts and so the
police i'm gonna call everybody so is
the school
everybody
i'm just gonna i'm not gonna let you go
over there because i'm not gonna put my
kid in this you hear what i'm saying so
like it's this delicate dance and we've
got this history on it this is a baby
girl that is screaming for adults in her
life to act like adults
you know what i'm saying and i know that
you're you're there like trying to cheer
her
husband on and
trying to get him to cheer on
x right i know you're in a weird spot
i just don't hear that people are
ringing the bell loud enough
like the matrix y'all dodged bullets if
she doesn't go to if she doesn't go to
get a criminal record out of this
just whiffed and she'd done this a year
and a half from now
then she's trafficking child pornography
you know what i mean
oh yeah oh yeah such a big deal
it is a very big deal and
you know a lot more
issues that like i i don't know i guess
the question turns to
how do i
get him on board i guess because
screaming
turn the lights on let her go over there
we know this is a a not good environment
for her
you know she lives with a man with a
child
and tells her tells her daughter that
we're not really together we don't love
each other and now she's going to go on
a vacation
and wants to invite another man
and we're like we can't send you like we
need to know where you're going but he
he doesn't
seem to think that it's his job to get
involved in that well she wants to go
there for the weekend or she wants to do
this he has he has no other jobs on the
planet that come before
protecting and saving my daughter
right
that's it i agree that's it
so
asking like
man
don't give a kid a loaded gun don't let
your kid go to a house where they give
kids loaded guns
in this i'm talking to you but i'm also
talking to the millions of people
listening to this
this is the same as if you go to your
in-laws or your grandparents or their
grandparents or your friends or i don't
care who it is
this young woman
is not going to i still think she's a
good kid does that sound crazy i still
think she's a good kid
yeah she's a 14 or 15 year old 16 year
old
young woman who's just trying to connect
with people
it's the adults in her life that are not
fighting for her
i agree so what i do with him
i would
i don't scream and i don't yell that's
just not how i operate in the world
i would scream and yell
if somebody has to rattle the adults in
this situation
and if you tell him i'm calling the
police and i'm taking these photos of
what's happening at that house with the
marijuana and the alcohol and the
the sexualized pictures of our teen
daughter over there i'm taking this to
the cops so they will go over there and
shut it down because you won't
the fact that your husband hasn't called
that other family and said my daughter
will never come to your home
and if i see this again i'm calling the
police on you
like what's he doing
you know what i mean like that's the
level of
like i'm not letting my 15 year old make
these hard calls because she's 15.
that's the level of
ringing the bells i'm calling the school
and saying i can't get any adult in my
in this daughter's in this young woman's
life with custody to protect her will
you help me because i'm a stepmom and
i'm watching this thing just get flushed
down the toilet because nobody seems to
care nobody seems to be fighting
nobody seems to be screaming and yelling
and banging on
things i don't blame a 16 year old for
taking delicious photos i just don't
because they're 16.
i blame the adults that handed them the
loaded weapon
[Music]
man
i'm heartbroken for her because she's in
a in a cycle now
that she can't get out of because she's
a child
please please please adult somebody step
up for her all of you step up for her
please i'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
hey what's up we are back hey don't
forget to
do a couple things for me please um hit
the subscribe button it's somewhere here
it's like there around hit the subscribe
button if you'll see us on youtube or if
you are listening to this
on
podcast or if you get podcasts and if
you have somebody in your life that you
think would would benefit from the show
please afford it on to them um the the
way this thing is continuing to grow is
just continuing to blow my mind it's
such a beautiful thing and i want to
keep getting the message out there's a
lot of people just like you out there
struggling hurting trying to get through
the day and we all need each other to
walk through this so thank you so much
let's go to cr kirsten in denver
colorado i almost didn't read i'm sorry
what's up
it's okay i get it a lot uh not much how
are you dr john partying rocking on i'm
not partying
it's the morning i'm not that cool
what's up
um so my question for you is how do i
stop worst case scenario thinking um and
be present in the moment without
discounting hard things that happen
so that usually means a thing happened
what was it
um so
my husband and i have been married for
about two and a half years and
um
i'm 29 okay
um and my husband right before christmas
was diagnosed with cancer oh jeez
wow
what kind of cancer
bladder cancer oh my gosh i'm so sorry
uh thanks
so
um i'm i'm really trying to
um as we sort of like go through this
weird process
to
like not
spiral
out of control with my thoughts and
worst case scenarios but also like
this is really hard and
um
i i just i don't know how to not let my
anxiety get out of control without like
also acknowledging and
that like this is this is hard and
that um
like this is happening and not just be
pollyanna about it and you know like oh
everything's gonna be fine because it
might not be right so what's what's the
what's the update right now
um so everything happened really really
fast and so i feel like we're still
really processing it so um
like within a couple of weeks of being
diagnosed he um had surgery to take the
tumor out and he had a round of
chemotherapy
um and so
they um
they got
they they got everything out and they
they did that round of chemo and so now
every three months he goes back in for
more testing to make sure that nothing's
growing back
so right now there's no there's no proof
that cancer is there
there's no proof that cancer's there no
we're just like watching for side
effects beautiful and we're watching for
like
for symptoms of it um
like uh there's a whole bunch of things
we have to watch for um and if we see
him then we have to call the urologist
and all of that
but every three months for the next two
years he'll go back in for
um for
tests to see if anything's come back all
right so i'm going to speak super
directly probably in a way that nobody's
spoken with to you is that okay
yeah because i'm your friend and i love
you and you're we're
we're neighbors now cool
okay
he might die
and then there's a period
right so there's a period at the end of
that sentence and the next sentence is
statistically speaking he's probably not
going to
period at the end of that sentence right
and every three months your body is
going to gear up to protect you
because you love him with everything
and that's okay if you weren't nervous
for these three month appointments i
would tell you to go see somebody right
away
that just means that you love him and
that you want him to be okay and that
when he's okay you're okay and if he's
not okay you're not okay that's what
that means yeah it's just your body
trying to love you okay so it's gonna
sound crazy let it
right so let it okay
you got to peek behind the curtain
that most of us don't ever get to peek
behind which is this we have this
illusion that we all get 93 years with
each other
yeah and then somebody
came into your house banging a cowbell
and you got to see behind the curtain
you're like oh this could go away at any
second
right
yep so your body's just trying to take
care of you because it loves you
so here's the here's the moving forward
part okay
has anyone let me pause here for a
second i know that's heavy
has anyone said out loud he might die
not out loud no okay so let's put it out
there
one of the things that's really
important for our bodies is to put this
stuff out there otherwise it starts
solving for these problems and it moves
its own
it moves the finish line on itself over
and over and over again
what i mean by that is
you have this overwhelming sense of doom
this and then you go to webmd and it's
for sure it's telling you everyone's
dying right oh yes everyone's dying
um and then you have this over the
shadow that's just laying over you and
so we go to the internet we go to
facebook go to
pinterest or whatever trying to solve
this thing
the solution comes from saying out loud
my husband's got cancer and this may end
bad
it's probably not going to because thank
goodness it's in such a sensitive place
that we were able to catch it early and
so far everybody's on the up and up and
they are unable to detect anything
and we know that the absence of proof
isn't the proof of absence but right now
we are celebrating like crazy because
what a win
yeah you see what i'm saying
yeah i think uh right now like
we we have a great support system but
like
everyone is trying to be super
supportive and positive in the only way
that they know how and so nobody says
things like that like nobody says
like yeah this really sucks and he could
die like nobody says that everyone's
just like oh he's 29 he's healthy he's
going to be fine like everything's going
to be fine okay so
just listening to you
in a minute and a half
just me saying that sentence out loud
instantly brought tears to your eyes
and then right now i can hear it in you
your shoulders have dropped
and then you start to get pissed why are
you pissed because your husband's
freaking got cancer and he's 29 it's not
supposed to happen like that
yeah and if you don't deal with the
anger and i don't say deal with it to
get rid of it if you don't acknowledge
it
pull up a chair
it's you're supposed to be angry
it's ridiculous
you look around at all your other
knuckleheaded friends and their stupid
husbands and they don't have cancer
you know what i mean yeah
yeah and bladder cancer what an uh like
i've got a family member right now with
bladder cancer that's a humiliating
cancer
yeah a lot of people digging around in
the goods you know what i mean yeah i
don't want that i don't go to these
appointments you know what i mean so
yeah and pull up a chair
now here's a couple of things that i've
seen walking alongside folks number one
you suddenly found yourself you alone
responsible for all the other people's
well-being around you
yup cause oh my gosh he's got kit and
suddenly you're trying to take care of
everybody else
not just him but like aunt martha and
his mom and your friends oh and now it's
their thing and now they're posting on
their instagram walls pray for dan
because dan's go and you're just like
what do you you know what i mean
yeah number two
you don't have permission to laugh
you don't have permission to crack up to
be silly
to when he screws up the dishes
even though he's wheeling a bag behind
him to go will you do the dishes right
you know what i mean
you haven't been touched
other than desperation hugs
you
have a right to have your full range of
hurt and your full range of joy
and every time you laugh and you start
to feel guilty because oh yeah he had
cancer
just that's when you stop that thought
train just stop it and go nope i get to
laugh
you know what else i get
that dude when he gets up takes the cold
peas off of his
off the
off the unit
he's gonna vacuum because he can do it
you know what i mean
yeah
so don't fall into the guilt trap of his
needs are more important than your needs
both of your needs matter here because
here's why
needs you to be strong and you can only
be strong if your needs are met too
okay
yeah
so decide what the next two weeks we're
gonna let's do this in bite size chunks
let's get to the next three months and
let's get to the next three months let's
get to the next three months
all right
and
as best we can
uh you may have heard me say this i
don't know if i've ever said it on this
show i've said it before but um so i
used to catastrophize financial stuff
all the time
wildly so
and i'm
just smart enough to get myself into a
hole that i can't get myself out of
and i would
write these things out and i'd find
another article another article another
article there's always somebody
confirming what i thought
and so i would meet with cfos i would
meet with all kinds of folk i had access
to some fancy pants money people and
none of them would if they said things
are going to be okay i would say well
you're dumb and so i got myself into
this spiral right the doctors probably
looked at you and smiled and said we got
it and you were like yeah but what if
you didn't right this is a oncologist
this is their profession this is who
they are and what they do
and they are trained not to give false
hope but you
kirsten the 29 year old wonder kid knows
more than the surgeons right more than
the doctors you're like yeah but you
probably what if you missed so here we
are
i had a buddy and he gave me this line
and it changed my life he's one of my
best friends on the planet
so he's a banker and i sat down i was
working through all the money stuff with
him i was like what about this what
about this what about this what about
this and here's his line
he finally looked at me and said john i
don't have a meteorite plan
i said what do you mean
and he said i got savings
i got rental homes i got investments i
don't owe anybody anything i got this i
got that
but if we get hit by a meteor right i
will deal with that then
if the u.s dollar just evaporates and
goes away and everybody's trading
digital art picture nfts for food i will
deal with that then because we'll have
way other problems right
so yeah i tell you
you can't have a meteorite plan
so what does it plan her i know you are
i know you are and part of this the
spiritual exercise here is opening those
tight hands
yeah
and not show so we're gonna plan but
we're playing for two weeks what do two
weeks look like what do i need in the
next two weeks
what does he need in the next two weeks
how can we meet each other's needs and
for the things that we can't
maybe he's got to go to bed at eight
o'clock cause he's still wiped out
awesome
two nights a week after you're in bed
i'm gonna go hang out with my
girlfriends and we're gonna laugh like
crazy
you know what i mean
yeah
you staying up at after he goes to bed
at eight staying up till midnight
researching crazy medical journals is
not helping
no it doesn't
no it just dumps gasoline on your face
all right so yes it does be gracious
when you with your body when it spins up
you almost
lost the wind in your lungs
you should be scared
yeah and
you can spray them with a water bottle
you can still do something sexy you can
still laugh at him you can still shove
him unless he's gonna fall over don't do
that if he's gonna fall over
you can still make jokes whatever
okay it's both end
yeah
and there may be something healing about
if you haven't already
holding his hands and looking him in the
eye
and saying the words i don't want you to
die
and him saying i don't want to die
either and you saying i need you here
say those words out loud and look him in
the eye
and then let him know we're in this
together
and by the way nice place to get cancer
dude
right
i know it's crazy he has no family
history of any like anything like that
but just like out of the blue
yeah i know and hey don't get struck by
lightning yes you did you yes yes don't
go don't spend your energy mining for
why and where it is it is
trust your doctors
they apparently really good
trust your doctors
plan for two weeks and then plan for the
next two weeks and plan for the next two
weeks and make sure you're a part of
that planning too what do you need
make sure you're eating make sure you're
sleeping make sure you're turning off
the stupid devices and not going down
rabbit holes and watching youtube clips
of some knucklehead like in an abandoned
warehouse like with the expose on
chemotherapy shut up with all that
hold that man's hand
and let that man hold your hand
and weep with him and laugh like crazy
and then when the three months comes up
your heart's gonna race you're gonna get
sick you're probably gonna throw up
you're not gonna wanna eat you're gonna
get diarrhea all those things and that's
okay
and then you're gonna have the next two
weeks and the next two weeks after that
next two weeks after that you're gonna
plan for the next three-month meeting
you're in it now you're in it let your
body love you and also know when to tell
your body ah i'm not doing that we're
not going down that road
i'm choosing a good day today
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video
phone even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't even have to see
anyone on a camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month so decide to invest in
yourself you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
hey real quick um something cool here i
i am a part of if you don't know i'm a
part of
ramsey solutions dave ramsey's team the
the get out of debt guy the change your
financial future change your family tree
um and one of the things that we dave
heard for years and years and years is
man how did i just learn at the age of
40 or 60 or 70 or 50 how did i just now
learn these principles about how to get
out of debt they should teach this stuff
in schools and dave was like well that
sounds like a great idea
so they created a
middle school and high school curriculum
i didn't know this before i started
hanging out here
um
one out of two high schools in the
country 45 percent of the high schools
in the country teach this thing more
than five million students have gone
through
the the financial literacy course so
it's
dave and the education team here created
a plug-and-play course to hand to
schools and say here you go
this is how to teach young people how to
handle money what taxes are what
economics is what stuff that we didn't
learn in school
and so then i
think man what an amazing thing and then
i think about the teachers and you all
know i've got a heart for teachers i've
been a teacher my wife's teacher my
friends are all teachers and professors
and they are getting crushed um james
gave me this this article here
a survey of u.s public sector workers
released in october found that k-12
public school educators were most likely
to report higher levels of anxiety
stress and burnout they're fried cooked
and this is every teacher i'm talking i
don't i have not spoken to a teacher
that says yeah dude i'm yolo i'm living
my best life
four in ten reported that work during
the pandemic has made them consider
changing jobs they're absolutely fried
so this is where we intersect here i've
got a deep heart for teachers
um and what they're going through and
have a deep heart for their students and
i also have work at a place that has a
deep heart for students and teachers
so there's this awesome
thing that we're doing here
teachers who have taught the person
foundation's personal finance curriculum
has changed a lot millions and millions
of kids lives april is financial
literacy month
and so we're celebrating all the
teachers in the country with a teacher
appreciation giveaway sponsored by the
borrowed future documentary that we put
out
teachers can enter today to win
cash we're not playing
we're not gonna give you a hug or an
apple or like special eraser set we're
gonna give you cash
a couple of teachers will win five
thousand dollars cash just to do
whatever you want with whatever you want
and then other teachers are gonna win up
to a thousand dollars cash and more so
teachers don't miss out on this and if
you have teachers in your life that you
love sign them up this is just cash this
is just us giving away cash because we
love you
we love you
we love you go to ramsaysolutions.com
teacher for a chance to win that's
randy's ramsay solutions.com teacher for
a chance to win all right let's take one
more call let's go to aaron in san diego
california what's up aaron how we doing
good doctor john thank you for taking my
call you got it brother what's up
um so i'm just calling um because i'm
wondering
how do i navigate interacting with my
manipulative and unfaithful
ex-girlfriend who just told me she's
pregnant with my child
whoa
didn't see that one coming
so give me a second here um
that's a lot man is it your kid
um we're going to get a
dna prenatal dna test good soon good um
today but
yeah it's scheduled
okay uh when it's
next tuesday excellent excellent
excellent okay very cool
yeah
um
what do you think you think this is you
um
i'm pretty sure um the
the dates and everything line up okay
but there is i'd say i'm about 85
percent sure it's fine okay cool
um so let's get the if you're not out of
the way if you're
not after this
interaction
blocker deleter walk away you know that
right
yes sir okay
if this turns out to be your child
then everything changes
first and most importantly this does not
mean you have to re-engage into a
romantic relationship with her right you
know that
yes okay
but
you were forever linked in a
relationship with her
so when you say
so i don't want to i don't want to think
that we're going to move forward here
without that connection okay you're in a
relationship with now because you all
made a human together
yeah when you say evil manipulative
cheating and all those things like tell
me more about that that sounds like
spurned lover talk
um
so we were
in a relationship for two years
and the first year
was really good it was
going exactly how
a good relationship should go
i was a little actually not a little i
was
putting way too much weight on the
relationship it was kind of
my whole identity was centered around
the relationship
and
she started seeing that
i was
really relying on her
and she would
she would ignore me towards the end of
the relationship she would ignore me for
like
three days without talking to me and
then come back and act like nothing
happened like we were great
um
and i would kind of
have breakdowns about that and she would
know
um and i think she just assumed i would
always be there for her
and she could
just
live her own life separate for me and
she had me under her thumb so she was
going to do what she wanted
but then
i found out that she
[Music]
was unfaithful cheated on me with a girl
and a guy
and
the girl was a one-time thing but the
guy she was in a relationship with him
for about three months while she was
with me
um
so i so that was let's back out so okay
um
you ever heard of heard me talk about
fundamental attribution error
uh no okay
it's just it's a nerdy psychological
term
and
i'm oversimplifying it but essentially
it's the idea
that we get in somebody else's head
and decide why they're doing whatever it
is they're doing
we judge their motives we judge their
thoughts we judge what they did and why
they did it and then we react based on
our interpretation of that judgment
okay
so you just laid out
these things that your
ex-girlfriend
did to you
and why she did them so i'm just gonna
play devil's advocate and get you give
you an alternative
uh narrative okay
okay my narrative could be
way off but i'm trying to hit the
pendulum the other way for a reason okay
could have been
that you were dating this young woman
things were great
and slowly over the course of a year
she was less and less and less able to
breathe
because this guy
became
a weighted blanket
because this relationship me was
everything
yeah and had to know where i was had to
know what was going on i had to breathe
and sometimes i just have to walk out
the front door
and i'm just going to disappear
not i'm not even thinking about him
i'm thinking about me
i have to breathe i still love this guy
i like him i like being with him
but he's a lot
and then
i run into somebody else who makes i i
start over time not liking who i'm
becoming forget the guy
i don't like who i'm becoming i'm
somebody who's short tempered i'm
somebody who's not fun anymore because i
can't breathe because my whole life is
trying to make sure this guy's okay
i'm becoming less of a romantic partner
and more of a mother
i don't like it makes me feel yuck about
me
and then i run into some other dude
who makes me feel alive makes me feel
wild and i screw up
and i don't know how to say it because
i'm married to someone i mean i'm dating
somebody
who has told me you're my oxygen if you
take this tank off i die
and so instead of breaking up with you
like she should have with integrity she
just slowly let you starve
she starts disappearing stops talking to
you for days just acknowledges you she's
done she just hasn't had the courage and
the integrity to break it off officially
and formally
and
you knew something was up
whether she was cheating on you or not
you may have not known that it may have
not been in your head but you knew
something was up
yeah
so here's why i told you that
you're gonna have to be in relationship
with her and you can only deal with you
that's it why she did what she did why
she's doing what she's doing all those
things you can't control any of that
and so spending energy thinking why
she's doing what she's doing and how
because of it that is just a choice for
for that you are making to be miserable
don't do that to yourself man you're
worth more than that
you might be about to be a dad
yeah okay
this is not how you plant how old are
you man
i'm 20.
all right
so let's put this this hat on that i'm
about to be a dad hat okay
yeah
if you get the paternity test back
it will be a shock to your system
and then
we are going to shift as fast as
possible into joy and to i'm gonna be a
great father
okay
i don't want another child being born
into
a couple of people who don't want them
here
yeah it's not how you drew it up it's
not you would have planned it if you
were you know but
you made some choices and here we are
right
so i'm gonna love this kid
sideways and forwards and to the moon
and back
i'm gonna respect his mom or her mom
i'm gonna be
i'm gonna not get in her head and try to
decide why she's doing what she's doing
and i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna show
up to the appointments even if she
brings some stupid boy with her
going to show up to the appointments i'm
going to treat every i'm going to bring
coffee for all three of us i'm going to
be a person of integrity even when i got
to go grip my teeth and go for a walk
myself
okay
who's i'm laying out i'm laying out all
the things that you can control
yeah because you can't control anything
else and now if there's another kid if
there's a kid along in this
you're it's there it's about them
my life is about me until i get married
and then it's about us until we have
kids
yeah right
so here we are
so
what i have found in my life that when i
get out of people's heads and i just
start dealing with what the deal is man
my life is a lot better
i'm not angry i'm not bitter all the
time
know what i mean
yeah that makes sense yeah for sure and
dude brother i don't want to make light
of you you got hurt bad didn't you
yes definitely okay what did you learn
about dating relationships this time
that i need to be
i need to be the best version of myself
before i get
in another relationship i need to be
able to be stable not relying on someone
else for my happiness that's awesome
hey when you get married i'm choosing to
lean up against you and they're choosing
to lean up against me
so there is some i i i kind of push back
a little bit when you're married i mean
i'm choosing to be dependent on you and
you on me like we're making that choice
yeah when i'm dating man i want to find
out who i am find out who you are and
how we're going to work together does
that make sense
yeah definitely
um
do you believe me when i tell you you're
worth laughing having fun
yes you're worth exercising you're worth
going to have a good life yeah
yeah okay
you for sure are
and
uh
ever since we broke up
which was about six months ago
i
have been really trying to do that
trying to
focus on myself and
better better myself
but this is i just don't want to go back
to that you know i don't want to yeah
fall back into those old patterns so
stay out of her head
stay in yours yeah stay out of her head
stay out of her boyfriend's head set of
whatever
and
even if you do this
this is gonna sound crazy and she might
i
again if you've ever listened to the
show you know i'm a comic i'm
obnoxiously optimistic about stuff okay
um
but what if you sat down with her and
had a conversation before the paternity
test came out
and said hey listen we dated for like
two years
and i was immature and i smothered you
and i'm so sorry
i realize now that i made it hard for
you to breathe
and whether or not um if this ends up
being um my my son
my daughter
i want you to know
i'm gonna love that baby
and i'm gonna partner with you over the
course of that kid's life to give that
kid a great great life
yeah what if you did that
yeah i i think that's a really good idea
that's all you can control and then if
she responds with like oh yeah
that's not you can't
you can't control that right yeah you
could know all right i'm not gonna have
these little uh a little like after
school special moment anymore but
you're controlling you can control
you're not excusing the fact that she
cheated on you that's wrong dude she
shouldn't have done that not excusing
the fact to cheat on you with multiple
people not excusing any of that kind of
stuff
but you're just looking in the mirror
and saying what can i control here
i want a great boyfriend and i'm gonna
do better next time i'm learning i'm
growing hopefully she's learning growing
too and she might even say i'm sorry i
cheated on you
maybe not maybe not
but maybe
maybe she'll weep and say
good
probably not but
but maybe right yeah
yeah responsibility will you call uh
shoot me a note let me know
yes definitely i will all right brother
we'll be thinking about you guys as you
move forward
everybody listening
get out of other people's heads i don't
i don't know why they're doing what
they're doing
they are and i'm gonna respond to what
they're doing because that's all i can
do
i'm gonna respond to my attitude i'm a
sprawling with my actions i'm gonna
respond with my thoughts because that's
all i can do
that's it
we'll be right back
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
we'll walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
so go to johndaloney.com to take the
next step towards wellness that's own
your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
so there's kind of been a shift from the
songs that i think are the greatest of
all time to
james and jenna and everybody in the
booth kelly
nate dog everybody in there uh
picking a song about the show that we
just had and so this is the lyrics they
handed me um this is actually nate's
favorite song of all time
from the one and only i don't know if we
could talk
from mj can we say that
the song is billie jean
just gonna leave it at that and here's
the lyrics
she was more than a beauty queen from a
movie scene i said
don't mind but what do you mean
i'm the one
who will dance on the floor in the round
[Music]
she told me her name was billie jean and
she caused a scene then every had turned
with eyes that dreamed of being the one
who will dance on the floor in the round
people always told me be careful of what
you do don't go around breaking young
girls hearts
my mother always told me be careful who
you love
be careful of what you do because the
lie becomes the truth billie jean is not
my lover she's just a girl who claims
that i am the one but the kid is not my
son
she says i am the one but
the kid is not my son i see what y'all
did here well played guys it took me a
minute but i just got it
i'm not the sharpest tool in the shed
but i'm glad you're here we'll see you
soon
coming up on the next episode is there a
way to paint with a broad brush
what people should broadly be doing when
it comes to eating i feel like it's just
chaos man you know anybody can be
proclaimed themselves an expert so many
people are confused because a lot of
influencers or people trying to sell
stuff whenever i hear a claim my first
thought is always hmm i wonder if that's
bs you know
like i i start there if you're a good
scientist skepticism is something that
you really embrace
[Music]